DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
♪ ♪
[LAUGHS]
YES, THIS JUST IN.
MARITIME SAYS BRETT KAVANAUGH
WENT THROUGH ICE CUBE'S IN A
BAR.
I KNOW.
ICE, FROZEN WATER SHAPED LIKE
CUBES.
OBVIOUSLY WE CAN HAVE THIS FIEND
ON THE SUPREME COURT.
IF HE TREATS ICE LIKE A WEAPON,
WHAT MIGHT HE DO WITH A SNOW
CONE?
THE WRITER OF THE PEACE HAVE
THIS ONE'S ON TWITTER DEEMED
KAVANAUGH A THREAT TO SOCIETY.
THE TIMES CALLED USING THIS
WRITER AN ERROR, MOSTLY BECAUSE
THEY GOT CAUGHT ONCE AGAIN.
BUT IT IS ICE.
>> POLICE DOCUMENTS THAT SHOW
BRETT KAVANAUGH THREW ICE IN
SOMEONE'S FACE DURING A BAR
FIGHT WHEN HE WAS IN COLLEGE.
DO YOU FEEL THAT IS IN ANYWAY
DISQUALIFYING FOR SOMEONE TO SIT
ON THE SUPREME COURT?
>> THIS IS WHY WE NEED AN FBI
INVESTIGATION.
THERE ARE A LOT OF ALLEGATIONS,
AND THE REPORTS REALLY ARE ABOUT
HOW HE BEHAVES WHEN HE IS DRUNK.
>> Greg: MAYBE THEY DO WANT TO
ABOLISH ICE.
YOU SEE WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
IT IS CALLED THE LIST.
WHEN INITIAL INCIDENTS ARE
UNCORROBORATED, YOU BUILD A MENU
OF EVEN MORE INCOMPLETE ITEMS TO
CREATE AN ILLUSION OF
CORROBORATION.
FIRST ICE, FINALLY JAYWALKING.
TALK ABOUT A PETTY CRIMINAL.
ACCUSER NUMBER THREE WHO FACED A
FEW ALLEGATIONS OF HER OWN,
FAILED TO NAVIGATE A Q&A.
>> DID YOU SEE BRETT KAVANAUGH,
YOU KNOW, SPIKING PUNCH?
>> I SAW HIM GIVING RED SOLO
COPS TO QUITE A FEW GIRLS.
I SAW HIM AROUND THE PUNCH.
I WANT SAY BOWLS.
THE CONTAINERS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE DID.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GOING TO
ASK.
EVERYONE IS WONDERING IF ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE WAS BRETT KAVANAUG
KAVANAUGH.
>> I CANNOT SPECIFICALLY SAY
THAT HE WAS ONE OF THE ONES WHO
ASSAULTED ME BUT BEFORE THIS
HAPPENED TO ME, AT THAT PARTY, I
SAW BRETT KAVANAUGH THERE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, HER LAWYER
MIGHT WANT TO HOLD OFF ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL RUN FOR NOW.
IT REMINDS ME OF A JOKE.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
JUNK IN A JOURNALIST?
JOURNALIST BLACKOUT WHEN SOBER.
THEY PASS OUT LIKE GOATS.
THIS AMNESIA ONLY BLOCKS OUTS OF
THE DOZEN FOR THEIR DESIRES.
INCONSISTENCIES, FEINSTEIN,
RACHEL MITCHELL'S MEMO.
THIS IS WHAT THE MEDIA HAS DONE
TO AMERICA.
THE ONLY ACCUSATIONS THAT MATTER
ARE AGAINST CONSERVATIVES.
NO BURDEN OF PROOF, NO NEED FOR
A WITNESS.
ALL YOU NEED IS AN ACCUSATION
AND THAT ACCUSER THEN BECOMES
THE PROSECUTOR.
THE LEFT ACCUSED THEN PUNISHED
FOR THE CAUSE.
SOMETHING WE SAW IN THE
SOVIET UNION AND CHINA.
ARE WE THERE YET?
WE AREN'T, BUT THE PRESS IS.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: GLAD TO BE HERE.
>> Greg: I READ THAT KAVANAUGH
WON'T BE RETURNING TO HARVARD TO
TEACH.
ANYONE WHO SAYS THIS IS A JOB
INTERVIEW AND NOT A CAREER
DESTROYING INQUISITION IS LYING.
>> Tucker: SOME HAVE FILED
SUIT UNDER TITLE IX SAYING HIS
PRESENCE IS A ACTIVE HOSTILITY
OR SOMETHING.
I'VE SEEN A COUPLE MOMENTS AND
49 YEARS WHERE MASS HYSTERIA
OVERTAKES US ALL AND I KEEP
THINKING AS I'M WATCHING THE
NEWS REPORTS DONE BY A LOUD
PEOPLE I KNOW, DECENT, SMART
PEOPLE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE LIKE WAKING
UP WITH A TATTOO 15 YEARS FROM
NOW AND YOU'RE LIKE I'M NOT EVEN
SURE WITH THESE TRIBAL SIGNS
STAND FOR.
AT THE TIME IT SEEMS DEEP AND
SIGNIFICANT AND OUTS OF PEOPLE
ARE ATTACHING SIGNIFICANCE
THINGS THAT ARE LUDICROUS THAT
ADULTS SHOULD DISMISS OUT OF
HAND.
HE HAS WRITTEN OVER 300 OPENINGS
IS A FEDERAL JUDGE.
NONE OF THEM ARE UNDER DEBATE.
INSTEAD WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HIS
YEARBOOK PAGE AND ICE CUBES AND
TOTALLY UNFOUNDED ALLEGATIONS.
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
I BELIEVE THERE IS A LIBERAL
CASE AGAINST BRETT KAVANAUGH.
WE ARE NOT HEARING THAT.
IT IS THIS GARBAGE.
>> Jesse: DANA HAS A TRIBAL
TATTOO, SO YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO APOLOGIZE.
>> Greg: THERE WAS THAT ONE
TIME I WOKE UP WITH A TATTOO.
YOU GREW UP IN COLORADO WHICH I
BELIEVE HAS SNOW.
YOU PROBABLY PACKED A HARD
SNOWBALL.
ARE YOU WILLING TO CONFESS IT TO
ANY SNOWBALL FIGHTS.
>> Dana: MY GRANDFATHER, WHO
WAS A RANCHER, HE WAS AGAINST
SNOWBALLS BECAUSE HE HAD
ACTUALLY SEEN A BOY HAVE IS I
PUT OUT BY SNOWBALL.
>> Greg: IT'S ALWAYS EYES.
>> Dana: I WONDER WHAT WILL
HAPPEN WHEN THEY FIND OUT HE PUT
A SPITBALL INTO A YOUNG GIRL'S
PIGTAILS IN FRONT OF HIM.
THEN WE WILL KNOW THAT THE
NOMINATION IS OVER.
>> Greg: ARE THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC SEEING IT FOR WHAT IT IS?
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK THEY ARE SEEING A LOT OF
IT.
WAS INTERESTING IS INTERESTING I
SAW A POSTING ABOUT INTERACTION
ON SOCIAL MEDIA ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
THE NUMBER ONE SITES FOR ALL THE
INTERACTIONS.
NUMBER ONE, FOX NEWS.
NUMBER TWO, BREITBART.
THREE AND FOUR WERE BEN SHAPIRO.
FOX NEWS AGAIN.
IN TERMS OF ENGAGEMENT, PEOPLE
WHO ARE TALKING ABOUT THIS,
INTERACTING ABOUT IT, YES, IT'S
ABSOLUTELY PENETRATING I THINK
ON THE RIGHT FOR SURE.
I THINK IT'S ALSO TRUE ON THE
LEFT.
YOU WILL SEE IT IN THE
FUND-RAISING NUMBERS CERTAINLY
FOR DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE RAISING A TON OF MONEY.
I DON'T THINK IT HELPS THEM IN
THE SENATE BUT IT COULD HELP
THEM WIN BACK THE HOUSE.
>> Greg: JESSE, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO REACT OF SOUND ON TAPE OF
DONALD TRUMP REACTING TO THIS?
WHY DON'T WE DO THAT?
I WANTED TO ASK FIRST.
>> I SAY IT'S A VERY SCARY TIME
FOR YOUNG MEN IN AMERICA WHEN
YOU CAN BE GUILTY OF SOMETHING
THAT YOU MAY NOT BE GUILTY OF.
THIS IS A VERY, VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT TIME.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE HAS MUCH
MORE TO DO THAN EVEN THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE.
>> Jesse: I THINK HE HIT THE
NAIL ON THE HEAD.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT ANYTHING.
I DON'T THINK MEN IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE THAT MUCH UNDER
ASSAULT.
HE HAS A GOOD POINT THAT ANY
ALLEGATION CAN BRING ANYBODY
DOWN IF THIS IS THE ENVIRONMENT
WE ARE LIVING IN.
LET'S GET THIS STRAIGHT.
SOMEONE THROWS ICE AT SOMEONE AT
A BAR AND DEMOCRATS WANT THE FBI
TO INVESTIGATE.
HILLARY CLINTON'S CLASSIFIED
EMAILS WIND UP ON ANTHONY
WINTERS LAPTOP TWO WEEKS BEFORE
THE ELECTION THE DEMOCRATS SAY
NO, FBI.
DON'T INVESTIGATE.
THE MORE AND MORE I HEAR ABOUT
BRETT KAVANAUGH, THE MORE AND
MORE I KIND OF LIKE BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
BRETT KAVANAUGH LIKES BEER.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE COME OUT
AGAINST THEATER.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
>> Greg: AND ICE.
>> Jesse: THIS IS PROBABLY THE
DUMBEST THING THEY DID SINCE
THEY CAME OUT AGAINST THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM LAST YEAR.
TERRIBLE POLITICS.
SOUNDS LIKE THEY WANT TO BRING
BACK PROHIBITION.
THE LAST TIME I CHECKED, TED
KENNEDY HAD A FEW DRINKS AND
THINGS DIDN'T GO TOO WELL.
BILL CLINTON WAS CREDIBLY
ACCUSED OF RAPE BY JUANITA
BROADDRICK AND REMEMBER HOW NBC
TREATED THAT?
THEY SPIKED THE 18 A BRODERICK
STORY AND THEY WENT FULL ON WITH
THIS WOMAN'S CLAIMS IN THIS
WOMAN IS BEING RUN, AS YOU CALL
HIM, THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER.
RUNNING AS A DEMOCRAT.
NONE OF HER ALIBIS CHECK OUT.
I'M THINKING TO MYSELF AND BE
NEWS SPIKED THE RONAN FARROW
STORY AND THEY GO WITH THIS?
THEY HAVE NO STANDARDS.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU CAN RESPOND
TO JESSE OR ANSWER MY QUESTION.
ISN'T AVENATTI THE BEST THING
THAT COULD HAPPEN TO
REPUBLICANS?
>> Juan: THEY ARE CERTAINLY
MAKING HIM INTO THAT.
>> Greg: HAS HE DONE ANYTHING
GOOD FOR THE DEMOCRATS?
>> Juan: AVENATTI HAS STORMY
DANIELS.
LET ME SAY JESSE'S AFFECTION FOR
JUDGE KAVANAUGH, AS A FELLOW
FRAT BOY.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
THIS STORY, UNLIKE WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT, IS ABOUT THE
JUDGES CREDIBILITY.
IF HE IS IN THE BAR ENGAGING IN
BAR FIGHTS ON THROWING ICE, THIS
IS A GUY WHO SAYS HE WAS A CHOIR
BOY.
HE SAID NOTHING LIKE THIS WAS
GOING ON.
>> Greg: HE NEVER SAID HE WAS
A CHOIR BOY.
>> Juan: THE PRESIDENT'S
COMMENTS, THESE ARE SCARIER
TIMES, SCARY TIMES FOR YOUNG
MEN.
THEN DON JR. IS ON RECORD SAYING
HE'S MORE AFRAID FOR HIS SONS
THEN HE IS FOR HIS DAUGHTERS.
WOW.
IN OTHER WORDS, PROFESSOR FORD,
WHO STEPS FORWARD, PUTS HER NAME
OUT THERE, COMES FORWARD AND
TESTIFIES BEFORE CONGRESS,
PROFESSOR FORD.
YOUR TRAUMA, YOUR DIFFICULTY,
YOUR LIFETIME OF TRAUMA --
STROKE WHAT WE ARE REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT HIS BOYS.
HOW RIDICULOUS?
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU HAVE SONS.
WOULDN'T YOU WANT THEM TO HAVE
DUE PROCESS.
>> Juan: HE WAS NOT CHARGED
WITH THE CRIME.
>> Greg: COURT OF PUBLIC
OPINION MAY BE WORSE.
>> Juan: HERE'S THE THING.
IF YOU PUT SOMEONE ON.
YOU SAY DID HE LIE?
HE SAYS --
SPECIFICALLY HE SAID HE HAD NO
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THIS NEW YORKER
ARTICLE AND THEN IT TURNS OUT
GUESS WHAT.
HE IS TRYING TO GET PEOPLE TO
REFUTE.
>> Dana: NO, THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> Tucker: MANY SAY THIS IS
NOT A LEGAL PROCEEDING.
IT'S A JOB INTERVIEW.
DUE PROCESS DOESN'T APPLY.
THE RULES OF BASIC FAIRNESS
DON'T APPLY.
IS THAT THE STANDARD YOU WANT?
HOLD ON.
FOR DUE PROCESS, IT'S A LEGAL
TERM FOR FAIRNESS.
IF I ACCUSE YOU OF SOMETHING, I
HAVE TO SHOW YOU DID IT.
THAT DOESN'T JUST APPLY TO
COURT.
IT APPLIES TO HOW YOU RAISE YOUR
KID AND HOW YOU DEAL WITH YOUR
WIFE AND YOUR COWORKERS.
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
STATEMENT?
>> Juan: IT'S SUSPENDING THE
IDEA THAT SOMEHOW YOU HAVE THE
RULES OF A CRIMINAL PROCEEDING.
>> Tucker: IT'S A VERY SIMPLE
RULE.
HOLD ON.
A SENATOR SAYS YOU ARE ACCUSED.
PROVE YOU ARE INNOCENT.
>> Juan: NO, IT'S NOT.
>> Tucker: THEY SAID THAT OUT
LOUD.
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH THAT?
>> Juan: YOU ARE DISTORTING
THAT.
YOU ARE NOT AS ATTRACTIVE AS
MOST PEOPLE WHO SIT IN THAT
YEAR.
>> Greg: I FIND THAT TO BE A
BIT SEXIST.
DANA NEEDS TO CLARIFY.
LET DANA.
>> Dana: THERE IS SOMETHING
THAT'S UNFAIR ABOUT THIS
SUGGESTION THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH
WAS TRYING TO COACH PEOPLE
THROUGH TEXT MESSAGES THAT THEY
WOULD CORROBORATE A STORY IN THE
NEW YORKER.
IT'S NOT THE CASE.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED.
HAVING BEEN THE SPOKESPERSON FOR
ROBERTS AND ALITO.
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU HAVE SO MANY
PRESS QUESTIONS ABOUT THINGS
THAT MIGHT'VE HAPPENED,
JOHN ROBERTS, THE BIG SCANDAL
WAS THAT HE WAS A MEMBER OF THE
FEDERALIST SOCIETY.
WHAT DO I HAVE TO DO?
I'VE GOT A CALL, WAS
JOHN ROBERTS A MEMBER OF THE
FEDERALIST SOCIETY?
WHAT HAPPENED, DO THEY GIVE A
SPEECH?
YES, I HAVE TO ASK ABOUT IT.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE YOU'RE TRYING
TO SQUASH THE STORY AND THAT'S
UNFAIR.
>> Juan: NO IT'S NOT.
>> Dana: YES, IT IS.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
GOING TO SAY IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THE REPORTER FROM THE NEW YORKER
WAS IN TOUCH WITH HIS ADVISORS
AND MAY BE HIM THEN HE REACHED
OUT TO PEOPLE.
REMEMBER, DANA, HE TESTIFIED
THAT HE KNEW NOTHING ABOUT THIS
UNTIL THE NEW YORKER.
>> Jesse: HE TESTIFIED HE
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE SPECIFIC
ALLEGATION WAS.
HE HAD GOTTEN WIND THAT THIS
WOMAN WAS CALLING AROUND.
YOU KNOW WHY SHE WAS CALLING
AROUND?
SHE DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS
KAVANAUGH.
SHE WAS SAYING TO HER FRIENDS,
WASN'T KAVANAUGH?
NOT SURE.
HE'D GOTTEN WIND SOMETHING WAS
COMING DOWN THE PIPELINE SO HE
SAID TO SOME OF HIS BUDDIES, I
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
LET'S MAKE SURE I DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING.
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> Greg: WE'VE GOT TO GO.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT JESSE IS
DOING THE OLD SYMBOL FOR A
TELEPHONE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: ONE LAST THING.
TOO MUCH FOR YOU, GREG.
YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR THE OTHER
SIDE.